[Music]
on today's show we talk to a woman who's
dealing with her husband's ex-wife and
child care issues we also talk to a
woman whose co-worker is threatening
suicide but laughing about it
we also talk to a guy who's struggling
with communication with his girlfriend
stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up what's up
this is john with the dr john deloney
show so glad you're with us
i say that every time but i'm glad
you're with us every time
maybe they're one day i'll say i'm so
glad you're with us and i'll be lying to
you but you won't even know it i'm glad
you're with us
talking about mental health
relationships what's going on in your
life and in the world
man so many podcasts and you chose this
one so i'm grateful thank you so much if
you enjoy this podcast send it to a
buddy um send it to somebody that may
need it or send it to somebody who's
struggling with some of the same stuff
that'd be awesome
and we're getting up on the holidays i
don't know when this goes out november
ish i'm assuming this will be sometime
in the novembers so don't forget john
bologna no vims cause i'm a i'm a middle
school girl i like just
totes
whatever
is that you're supposed to be like
you're a free stop just keep moving all
right so go to johnology.com go to
joedlow.com
johnodelyn.com nope that sounded weird i
don't know what joe delo is that may be
real bad go to johndaloni.com
and um
get the conversation cards for your
family for your trip for traveling for
you and your husband you and your wife
just staring at each other
and you think let's go on a date and
then you're gonna stare at each other
you have to talk about your kids you can
learn about each other
and then when you're with your in-laws
who just want to talk about conspiracy
theories oh my gosh did you know there's
this youtube channel hey just be like
hey look i got these cards let's ask
these questions it'll save everything
everything
including the planet john dolan dot com
slash cards let's go to merianya in
los angeles california what's up how are
we doing
good in yourself dr john man we are
rocking on is it super super super early
yeah well yeah i came early to work to
make it on time but yes it's super early
hey what is that like getting to work
early on time does that feel good
i have a fantasy that it feels so good
it does feel good um but the other day i
set off the alarm in the building and i
didn't know what to do because i just
got a promotion here so that was pretty
scary
you get a promotion and you're already
breaking and entering good for you way
to go marianna that's awesome so hey
what's up congratulations on your
promotion by the way that's pretty rad
thank you thank you so much
uh well my question today is in regards
to uh a disagreement i have with my
husband
i love getting in the middle of these
excellent
it's in regards to child care um
more so with his ex so so we have four
boys our three older ones are from his
previous marriage
and
we have them friday through sunday and
their mom has them monday through
thursday okay and there's been quite a
few times now uh more so
in the beginning it seemed like
emergencies where she
either couldn't miss work or
or someone got sick one of the boys
things like that
so
the only person that could be there is
my mom because my mom
takes care of our little son so so she
would go and either pick up
the kids from school or take care of
them if they didn't have school whatever
the case may be
and now it's more so that she's because
she has been relying
fully on my mom and and my mom kind of
just thought it was it was temporary and
she recently last week told us that she
doesn't want to um you know i guess
quote-unquote help her if anything she
doesn't want to take care of the boys
when it's on her time she needs to
either figure it out because she has a
lot of family so my mom has this
perspective that you know she she has
other ways and asking for us for help
um
and and it's true because the only
person that we would trust to take care
of the boys in any circumstance would be
my mom which is not all the time because
we're usually we are there i should say
we are there for them uh when when it's
our time sure so hold on i'm kind of
getting lost here so
you and your husband you'll have a
little one right now together yeah and
he has
some other kids some other boys from a
previous
relationship
and
his ex from the previous relationship
y'all share custody so i'm gonna take
you out of this so him and his ex share
custody
and he gets them some of the time and
she gets them some of the time
and
once or twice your mom
bailed them out
your mom helped out with child care
helped your husband's ex
out with child care
right
and then all of a sudden your husband's
ex liked that it was free and always
accessible and now it's turned into an
all the time thing and your mom is
saying i didn't sign up to take care of
your husband's ex's kids i'm out
right and and she loves she loves a boy
she's probably the best grandma that
they have and and i love that but in and
it's not more so it's not her job
doesn't want it's not she doesn't want
yeah
and and my husband now you know has
a connotation of her that she
said it's not about
his ex it's about the boys we have to
take care of the boys all the time and i
totally get that honestly life would be
a lot better if i burst my kids you know
myself like it's hard to it's hard to
try to make her responsible if that
makes sense or how do we do that how do
i get myself here here's here's the
thing
your mom
is a grown woman
who can do whatever she wants to do
right
and if she wants to
help with child care great
if she doesn't
great she's allowed to do that
and you and your family looking at her
and saying y'all are abandoning us you
don't love us you have a responsibility
to do these things
is inaccurate not true that's not fair
to your to your mom
right i'm proud of your mom for
putting a boundary up and saying hey i'm
running out of weeks and months of my
own life
and i want to do some things that don't
include bailing out your husband's
ex-wife or ex-girlfriend or whatever she
is
yes and so that stinks for you all
because you all have to come up with
some more money or more importantly
these boys birth mom
is going to have to
get her stuff together
and if she puts them in situations where
they're not safe that's what you and
your husband but your husband's going to
go first
are going to go back to court and seek
full custody because she's putting him
in situations that aren't safe but
that's between y'all
not your mom
right
and that's what i try to explain to him
because because he tells me well you
rather have them stay with strangers and
that's not i would never do that right
but
you're you're
that's that's gaslighting at its finest
that is blaming somebody else for their
boundary
that's not the only option the other
option is you all hire somebody that you
trust
and y'all don't go out to eat as much or
y'all
have to live in a different house that
is less expensive or drive different
cars i mean there's some major
sacrifices to having as many kids that's
not your grandma's responsibility i mean
it's not your mom's responsibility it's
not their grandma
a once a month
or an arrangement where y'all pay her
something like that
i'm all in on that but it's if she draws
a boundary she drew a boundary
right
when somebody draws a boundary we can
run up against it and it's normal i do
the same thing
run up against it and
crash into the boundary and see if it's
real
and
when you find out it's real then you
have two options you can respect the
person and their boundary or you can go
to war with the boundary it doesn't
change the boundary it just changes how
much your life is good or how much your
life sucks
and so
i would honor the fact that your mom has
boundaries and then just be about
deciding what's next it's not either or
there's 50 different options here
something about this makes me think your
mom feels taken advantage of and i think
she might be right yeah
yeah and i feel the same way and i i
agree with her but i also don't want my
husband to gain resentment towards her
because of it because he's not he's not
understanding what i what i think and i
understand where he comes from i mean he
grew up in foster care he wants to be
the best daddy absolutely absolutely he
is but
i i can't help him
get over that guilt that's not for him
if that makes sense that's right so can
i tell you a really hard thing that's so
so challenging and difficult and
heartbreaking
you can't control him
you can't control his thoughts you can't
control his actions you can just love
him
and you can have your own boundaries
and one of my boundaries would be
hey we're not going to talk bad about my
mom anymore she's made her choice and
now we're going to make other decisions
either one of us is going to quit
working for a season and stay at home
and we're going to deal with the loss of
income or we're going to hire somebody
but this is the reality that we're faced
with and it's not her responsibility to
make our fantasy about a perfect little
family
come true
or we may circle back to mom and say hey
mom can we hire you
and x is going to
spend the money because it's her
responsibility because it's her time
that she's keeping these kids right
right
and if she can't do that then she can't
do that
and unfortunately you're
there's not i don't see an unfortunate
here other than the pictures is
everybody wants it to be a certain way
that it's just not
and the quicker you all make peace with
that and then come up with the next plan
oh my gosh man so much more peace
involved there and you just can't hate
on your mom for saying hey whoa whoa i'm
getting taken advantage of here
yeah yeah and if x doesn't want these
boys then x and your husband need to
have a hard conversation about that
right if she wants the idea of wanting
these boys but doesn't want to be around
for him doesn't have time to be around
for him doesn't have the money to pay
for child care that's a court situation
that's a full custody situation that's a
whole different picture
right right
yes
i know this is so hard mariana i know
it's hard about it's hard on your mom
it's hard on you because you want this
thing to be beautiful and perfect
and your husband's heartbroken right
yeah yeah yeah he is
i'm so sorry
it's a messy messy situation
but on honor your mom's boundaries here
i'm going to sit down with your husband
and say
my mom has made a boundary
and so we're going to be done hating on
mom
she's bailed out your ex for
x number of years she's done with that
she's let us know respectfully cool now
we have to make other decisions let's
make other decisions and let's focus our
energy there and every time the
conversation goes back to well if she
would just the conversation's over that
part of our life is done
let's decide we're going to do next
carrying that brick around is a waste of
time and then when you see her on
thanksgiving hug her
she's been bailing you all out for years
hug her she made her call
i know it's so hard man i know it's so
hard and this has a lot of baggage for
your husband too he's carrying a lot of
the stuff he's carrying it with him
because he remembers his childhood and
he wants it to be different from his
boys
it can be different and it will be
different and he is a great dad and
you're a great stepmom
here but it's gonna look different than
the fantasy that he's got in his head
and that's okay he's gonna work hard to
make it happen we'll be right back on
the doctor john delaney's show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john de loni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
deloney
we are back with lynn and henderson
lyndon henderson that kind of rhymes i
like that i'm gonna i'm gonna sing this
song all day what's up lin
hi doctor john how are you
i'm good how are you outstanding
outstanding what's up
hey so i have a question for you
um i'm a teacher and i have several like
teacher assistants who work for me oh
god bless you um
oh my gosh wow
what do you what grade do you teach
um i'm actually a special education
teacher i work with students with uh
behavior
challenges and trauma backgrounds
quadruple
i'm making all of the i don't have a lot
of religious hand signs i don't know a
lot of them but i'm making all the ones
that i know um at you good for you good
gosh so you are someone who works with
children with
behavior challenges and
childhood trauma and you decided you
know what else would be fun just to
bring in some student teachers
well they're not student teachers
they're teacher assistants like they are
um
they're there to have a full-time job
okay excellent yeah yeah all right
that's not quite generally
thanks although i have had student
teachers too
teaching assistants are actually awesome
i've got a couple of friends who are
teaching citizens they're great they're
incredible yeah all right so i keep
interrupting you go ahead
so i generally have between five and
seven um each year right now i only have
three who are a little short staffed uh
however
i have one
right now she's kind of um she's
throwing me for a loop she
she kind of just says off color things
um which i've stopped in front of the
kids but she'll say things like um
well does anybody have some bleach water
i can drink or guess i'll just go take a
bubble bath with a toaster tonight or i
just think i'm gonna go kill myself so
she stopped saying those in front of the
kids because i
like i stopped that but she said that in
front of a couple teachers recently so
then they came and talked to me so then
we had a meeting with my principal we
kind of talked about professional
language
um you know and you know what it looks
like to be professional she's 21 she is
young um but
she just says you know her her comeback
is this is just how i cope this is how i
cope with life so my question to you is
is that really like is that a coping
skill should i be more concerned
um i just like i mean she's just putting
me a little bit on edge because of what
i do for a living and the kids i work
with absolutely
so number one
you're good for you thanks for
i'm glad you had like i'm i'm thinking
in my head yeah this needs to be
escalated have a professional
conversation here
um
the
i i don't buy that for a second this is
how i cope
not even for eight seconds not for half
of one second that's nonsense there's
professional behavior
and then there are
cries for help
and so
you my first thought would be yeah bring
her to your office maybe with the school
counselor and you went with the
principal awesome and have a very direct
conversation
and
here's how i handle this when somebody
makes let me back up i used to make that
joke too a lot
and i thought it was so egregious and
silly
that it was me just being off color
right just being like oh man i might as
well just go like whatever i can't even
do it as a joke anymore because i've
been around it so much
um but when i was 21 i did that all the
time i thought it was funny and it
wasn't and it took a couple of people
interviewing it may have been one of my
lead high school teachers that was like
dude that's not funny um or it may have
been me just dealing with that situation
and realizing this isn't funny but
all to say is i've been there it's not a
coping mechanism
when somebody says i might as well go
drink bleach water here's what i do or
i'm gonna go ahead and just take a bath
a toaster in it or something like that
i call in the
how do you say it cavalry is that right
the cavalry
um i would sit somebody down take him
directly out in the hallway and say i
need to know right now are you going to
hurt yourself
and let them know i don't play around
with this stuff and i would have a card
that says here's resources if you are
feeling like hurting yourself i want you
to call somebody
and if i hear this again i'm going to
call 9-1-1
okay i'm going to ring every bell i have
because you keep telling me that you're
going to kill yourself
and y'all had the professional
conversation i think next is time for a
write-up this is not this is not funny
okay in a context with trump traumatized
children i'm telling you as your
supervisor i don't think this is funny
and here's the thing let's take suicide
out of the conversation it could just be
fart jokes
or like butt crack jokes i think those
are hilarious i've been told probably
not in this meeting don't do that you
know what i mean
and so i can i didn't have a choice to
make
am i going to keep this job or not
that makes sense it seems so simple to
me
you are brilliant and you're empathetic
and to do the work you have to do you
have to have really firm boundaries
where is this getting sideways with you
there's a part of you that feels
suddenly on edge where is that
well i guess so
do you think she might be serious
well i have asked her point blank and
then she'll be like no
[Music]
i
i just yeah i just i i'm always very
careful like to be very direct with her
when when this has come up both times
but then i just like i just because of
what i do and because of the position
i'm in i mean i'm i'm taking care of
other people's kids like i just want to
be very
sure that um you know the people that
are in my room are you know that they
can do their job that they absolutely
are absolutely you know they're
clear-headed because we get in some very
um unique precarious positions you know
things really get moving in my room
sometimes so so you have to make sure
that people are
i handle those like i've been a
classroom i've been hitting the face
before by a high school student i mean
i've been in it yes
i handle those
things through off-color humor
through laughing through
we always like i've shown up to crisis
scenes and we're laughing sort and i
remember one time i was being at a scene
with a some folks and we were dealing
with some of the most bananas situation
you can imagine
and i was laughing so hard like my body
just
clicked over
and i don't i to this day don't know
what happened but i was laughing so hard
i remember thinking if somebody sees
this on video we're gonna we're getting
um we're gonna be institutionalized like
this why are we laughing so people
handle that stuff differently
but you also have to have enough body
and
social awareness to not do that in front
of a grieving mother or in front of a
hurt child you know what i mean
and so
i it sounds like a maturity issue with
me
if you think they're playing and hey you
don't play with suicide period but if
you think they're she's just playing and
this is how she's dealing with some of
the trauma she's seeing
yeah i mean it's time for a write-up
this doesn't happen again not not in my
classroom if you've got friends or
whatever but you're not gonna do that
and if you're gonna hurt yourself okay
here's one important thing i wanna make
sure i hand her a document whether it's
a small laminated thing the school
counselor may have something here are
resources
that for for you to call if you need
help or care and i'm sure that with the
school district there are uh
what do you call them um
esa i mean there's people that you can
go reach out to for counselors things
like that but
right and if it's uh even remotely
serious i call 9-1-1
we're gonna draw all the sirens get
everybody in here and you're gonna have
to sit down and look at a professional
and do a um do an assessment because i'm
not trained to do that do you feel
comfortable doing that
oh yeah yeah i can do that
all right
you're awesome
well thank you and tell her to call me i
would love to talk to somebody
who like
i'd love to talk to her that's such a
fascinating excuse i can't imagine
wrapping that excuse up this is just how
i cope y'all just deal
seems strange
is there something else here i feel like
i'm missing something
no i i know i just she definitely has um
a wrecked home life there's definitely
stuff there um
so i i do i think that she i think she
needs professional help she's 21. i mean
i feel like in some ways my hands are
tied i've you know i've given her
direction to go see a counselor but i
can't force her yeah you know like i
just there's like i guess when you said
like i seems like i'm kind of stuck i
feel like i'm stuck because i feel like
in one sense we are her safe place like
she comes to work because she feels
accepted
and loved here and yet i know i also
have to be this is my job and i have a
professional night to keep these kids
safe and so i just want to make sure i'm
walking that line oh gosh okay can i say
this this is real important
okay
counselors
i'll even go with doctors
teachers
who
use clients
students patients
to prop themselves up
do not need to be in those situations
and
i've worked with people closely in
in
with what you just described
which is this is their safe place
she her heart is filled up because she's
got a group of students who love her and
will lean on her and she can be the kind
of the funny one and the young one and
the jokes one and oh come on guys you
know what i mean
but she's using those kids to prop
herself up
and that is dangerous
that's how people say things and and get
involved in things and do things that
otherwise hurt kids and by the way kids
can feel that when they feel like their
job is to make sure the person that is
interacting with them needs to be okay
um
[Music]
kids can absorb that and so if you get
any sense that
she quote unquote needs these kids
not loves them and is engaged in working
with him
but needs these kids
needs this job to be okay
psychologically
that's a that's a rough place to put
those kids in
okay does that make sense
it does okay
and i know that's really hard you said
it best you can direct her to
to care you can direct her where to go
to resources
and she's a 21 year old adult and she's
got to make that choice
oh i hope she makes that choice
and you can't fix her home life and you
can't save her
you can give her options and say i love
you and as far as i'm concerned i'm
going to call in the authorities every
time i love you this may not be the
place for you to work
because you need to get well before we
put you in front of a room full of
children with challenges with any sort
of child but especially children with
challenges
who need centered connected
firm-footed adults in their life
because those kids got to anchor into
something
thank you so so much lynn i'm so
grateful for you i know this is a hard
situation thank you for being who you
are and for doing what you do we'll be
right back on the dr john delaney show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndeloney.com and
get your copy of redefining anxiety
today
let's take one more call i feel like
singing today this is like
a podcast musical theater you know who'd
be terrible at musical theater this guy
not great at musical theater
did you ever do musical theater ben
i never did i did marching band
i bet you're incredible at that huh
i was drumline drumline you look like a
drumline guy that's incredible good for
you kelly band
uh no dance team
i absolutely can see that
i'm not even gonna make a comment let's
go to jesse in seattle i want to stay
employed hey jesse what's up
hey uh good morning good morning to you
what's up dude
hey man um shoot it's crazy uh usually i
hear you and little
older people talking um so now maybe you
get to hear a 20 year old talking maybe
you can help me out you're 20.
yeah yes sir dude you don't number one
dang don't call me sir
i'm only 24. and that's not true
and you sound older than 20 did people
tell you that
um yeah and then the look too i kind of
have a kind of a beard so they tell me
that too oh people with beards
i have you can't see me right now but i
haven't shaved like in nine months i got
nothing oh i got no no i've seen it
before um i don't think i've ever seen
it with a beard because i can't grow one
it looks all patched out and scratched
out like i've lived in the woods for a
few months
and
and i i don't want to get too gr yes i
can't grow up here dude what i wish
would be awesome so good for you i'm
glad you look like an old lumberjack
congratulations
thanks thank you do you wear filson
you're from seattle you wear filson and
like cool thick
like plaid shirts
no
no no i'm on the other side carhartt
jeans boots oh dude real working stuff
because yeah i'm a truck driver actually
you're all the things i'm not jessie so
thanks for kicking me while i'm down
sure appreciate it
sure man gotcha all right so let's see
what we can do here what's up
um so i've been in this uh relationship
um with this chick i i really like her
she's great for about seven months now
seven eight months okay and i'm having
i'm not sure if it's still like a
learning thing or i'm still trying to
learn her um or if it's a me thing or
her thing but um
it's i'm having a little trouble
communicating with her when
we're in the disagreement when we're in
argument i'm the type of person to
um
like if something's bothering you let's
sit down let's figure it out right now
she wants to take a break
she wants some space
was it was real hard at first to kind of
get used to because i don't like
carrying like this stuff i just want to
get done and over with
and um but
i think something else is that
she'll have her space and whatnot but um
she just won't want to come back to the
table and talk about it
and i mean i i think eventually you know
we're going to have to talk about stuff
and it's not something like super
important it'll be just like little
disagreements and they'll just kind of
blow up and
um i'm wondering how i can get through
to her i mean it's kind of a
i'm not sure if it's like a deal breaker
or not
um
i don't mean to offend anybody out there
any any woman's out there but i really
don't but
i'm trying
at first i i thought it was uh sort of a
once a month type of thing
um i was trying to think of all my
options and i really hope i didn't find
anyone out there but um yeah i noticed
that
[Applause]
i don't know if you fit
i wouldn't say that i mean i wouldn't go
searching for
yeah i would take that off the table um
well i'm seeing now that that's not the
case anymore
yeah could be a little bit more often i
guess
yeah often but more randomly
so
hmm
how can i help let me ask you that
because let me start answering a bunch
of questions i don't even know that
you're asking how can i help sure
how do i
i guess how do i
how do i communicate with her when we
have a
okay
so do you like this this young woman
oh yeah yeah i love her okay
does she like it when you call her my
chick
um
i've never called her that uh oh just to
me
yeah
yeah so
here's here's what i've picked up in a
few minutes
of just talking with you
you're
um
you're super capable
my guess is you can fix stuff my guess
is you're strong you clearly have a
beard for god's sake you wear a carhartt
which is just awesome
um
you're able to just fix stuff you're
secure
and
it's hard when you're working on a car
there's not a car that you can't fix
you can just solve it
and so now you've come up against
somebody
and your way of solving things to fix
things there's a
lug nut that's missing let's replace the
lug nut and get on down the road
hey the car needs gas let's put gas in
it what do we do i don't know why i have
to discuss this let's put gas in and
move on down the road here
and
your girlfriend's behaviors to me
suggest she doesn't feel safe with you
she doesn't trust you
and not in a you're gonna cheat on me
kind of way
but in a
um you've already got her figured out
and you're the smart one and you've got
all the answers
and
she just needs to get on with it
and what she's trying to communicate she
doesn't she's not trying to communicate
this what her body is communicating is
i need some space
i'm not okay
and i feel like if i tell you what's
going on you're just gonna say well
don't think that way just do this
and is that fair
yeah no yeah it is no it is
and
often but she knows come around she does
say stuff like that
yeah so
and then when you throw in like
oh it clearly can't be me
it must be that she's having a period
or
it clearly isn't
like a
i mean there's the answers right there
clearly
so it must be that
fill in the blank
all of this is
um
is somebody's alarm bells going that
guy's not safe and i still love him
but i still want to be around him and so
safety is not you can't fight people i'm
sure you can um safety is
not that you don't earn a living you
clearly do safety is like if something
break air conditioner breaks that guy
can help me out great what i'm talking
about safety is
the amygdala part of somebody's brain
human connection
a sitting down and being quiet and
saying tell me what's going on and i'm
not gonna try to solve you i'm not gonna
try to give you all the answers back i'm
just gonna listen
now can she be bananas and bonkers and
fighting about that of course man but
she's been on the phone with me only
person i can i'm talking to is you right
so to go back to your original original
question man i've been with the same
person for 25 years
we've been married 19 and a half of them
um i'm still figuring out ways to
communicate
we're still working through that that is
part of a relationship you will change
over time she will change over time and
you're constantly negotiating what
communication looks like
the greatest gift you can give somebody
is safety
meaning if i tell you what i really feel
right now
you're gonna go thanks for sharing that
with me not that's stupid
or why don't you just do this you tell
that guy he just needs to
that's not what they're looking for
they're looking for your answers looking
for your connection
and that's hard for a bearded carhartt
dude right
it's dude it's hard for me who has no
beard and has these wannabe carhartt
pearl snaps on right now
i i love the same thing i it's hard
and i will tell you this brother
i have
i've hurt my wife with my charts and my
graphs
i've hurt my wife over the years
by
ignoring how she feels
and ignoring the thoughts she has
and her emotions and just trying to get
to quote unquote answers because i found
out a few years ago
she's way way smarter than me she
doesn't need my answers she just wants
me to be with her does that make sense
yeah so my question for you brother is
do you even want to be with this person
i mean
i i absolutely do um do you like her i'm
young but i do do you love her
yeah i do
okay
so
do you want to be right
or do you want to be in a relationship
with her
well i guess big picture's you know the
thing and i'd rather be with her
okay
because what i'll tell you over time is
hey that wasn't a very secure answer but
i'll i'll just go with it
over time right is going to be through
connection will there be moments you
have to say hey look this guy is for a
real blue yes
that's just not every time
i don't think this is a deal breaker at
all
i think you need to reorient yourself
that you're not the smartest strongest
baddest dude in the world
and that she has something to offer you
not vice versa
is that am i way off tell me i'm way off
you know it it makes sense
um it really does it clicks with me but
um
uh
i'm kind of worried if it's kind of it's
if this is going to be like the
like an always type of deal because her
family is like that there's this one
time and i picked up on it really quick
i
i was on the phone with her and um i
kind of heard like some
yelling in the background i guess her
younger sister was like arguing with her
mom she comes from like a mom dad family
um and i guess her mom and her sister
were arguing and it was like kind of
like they were kind of yelling at each
other and then i i kind of asked her
what happens next and she's like well
they never talk about it they just
go on
because days after um she told me
something like her mom was picking up
her sister oh they get along now and
she's like yeah no they yell at her
they're each other they have their their
their fights and then they just never
talk about it and they go about their
normal lives
and so i kind of went kind of aha like
is this possibly maybe this is what
she's used to is this kind of like where
it's coming from or is it still
i don't know i just thought maybe it was
worth saying if this was it might be it
for sure might be and here's the deal
you're bringing stuff from your past to
this relationship too
the difference is you've judged yours as
the right way and hers is the wrong way
and what i would suggest you do is to
stop saying either or and y'all develop
y'all's way
and some of that will be you sitting
down with her and creating an
environment where she doesn't feel like
you're gonna judge everything that comes
out of her mouth or beat her up with
your charts in your graphs because you
can have violence in a house two ways
you can have violence with facts and you
can have violence with silence too
and she haunts you by just walking away
and saying i need some time
it haunts you right
and you haunt her
by saying
well just quit eating that that's why
you're fat
and and i just made that up i don't
think you'd ever say that please tell me
you don't say that okay
i'm trying to be egregious here
but people say no i'm just telling the
truth man i'm just saying like you know
you solved that problem well dude
there's not the
yes you're factually correct and that
hurts people you know what i mean
and so your answers can be just as
painful for her as her silence is for
you
and so instead of saying i have the
right way i was raised the right way and
i can see from the way your parents did
stuff
man you got it the wrong way and i don't
know if
man you can look at life like that i'm
gonna tell you you're gonna be lonely
or you're gonna have all these answers
you have all these figured out you're
gonna spend a lot of time on the
internet
or
you can come down and say man in my
house we just did it like this tell me
about how you did it in your house
and
we get to create how we do it in our
house which means i'm going to have to
learn
that when you come and say hey this
happened at work today you're not asking
for my opinion on what to do next
you're just inviting me into your life
and you're going to have to learn that
when i'm frustrated i want to have a
conversation sooner rather than later
and you can't hide from me
does that make sense
yeah and i'll totally
yeah and so i want you to approach this
with humility not with i've got this
figured out and she needs to know if
she's going to get on the jesse train
it's less about is she going to figure
out the right way that you do things or
are you all going to figure out the
right way that you all do things and the
way you all do things will change over
and over and over again throughout time
now hear me say does she need to take a
break yep does she need to circle back
and have conversations and face things
head-on with you i think that's healthy
and i think that's wise yes
i do
i don't think that's a stick to to beat
her up with though
i think she's gonna have to learn a new
way of doing things and i think you're
gonna have to learn in a way of doing
things too would you agree with that or
tell me i'm crazy
no yeah no i i agree so will you stick
by her side while she learns a new way
to love somebody
absolutely yeah will you commit to her
to learning a new way to love somebody
too
yes will you never ever ever as long as
you live bring up her periods again as
an excuse for why she did something
ever no i won't ever
i won't do that ever
and this is just a personal thing it's
probably because i have a daughter dude
but
i don't know dude don't call the girls
chicks i don't maybe that's cool i don't
know i i i don't know
no i don't call it call well you do you
call her to me call her
my i don't know call whatever i don't
know i'm trying to think of the things i
call my wife and
i don't know
treat her with the utmost deepest
respect
as though she was created on earth just
for you
and love her like that not like a puzzle
to fix or an engine to tune up
and then in a year if you find out man i
have cherished her
i have dug deep in jesse i've tried to
figure some stuff out i've tried to be a
little more quiet and a little more
honoring and a little more tell me how
that feels man
thank you for sharing that with me
yeah absolutely and try that and if
after a year dude that's not a thing or
after two months six months like this is
too much work that's great that's why
you're dating y'all aren't married
but my guess is you're going to find a
lot about jesse
and you're going to find a lot about her
and dude
can i ask can i ask you one more quick
question i know we got to wrap up
sure
are you scared of how much you love her
um no
no
no because sometimes i've seen guys in
your situation
come up with reasons to leave somebody
before
they get left
no i don't think i'm i'm on that boat
she's all in on jesse
i think so i know so awesome so try this
and then shoot me an email and tell me
that was the stupidest thing i've ever
done
i want you to call her today
and say listen i talk to uh you don't
tell her you talk to me
or you can
say hey i think that
for the last six seven months
i've acted like i'm right all the time
and that you've got all these problems
and i want you to know that i love you
and i'm gonna start doing a better job
of just listening to you
and i'm gonna do a better job of hearing
you out and honoring your space and
here's the magic words
i want us to go have breakfast somewhere
and talk about
ways we could communicate better with
one another
and just be quiet and see what she says
she'll probably faint and you'll have to
hang out for 15 or 20 minutes until she
comes back too
my hope is she'll say
man that's awesome let's go to breakfast
she may say you're an idiot and i want
my old bearded truck driver back that
may happen that's her prerogative too
but man
if you can practice
letting her teach you what safety feels
like for her
man she'll be willing to have those hard
conversations she'll be willing to lean
into some of that hard stuff and i'm not
saying it's soft i'm not saying be like
no dude
i'm saying is
y'all co-create what this thing's gonna
look like together
you're a good man jesse she's lucky to
have you
never talk about periods and chicks
again all right good that's the last
time i'll say that all right as we wrap
up today's show
man
i'd literally just grab this off the top
didn't even set this up
this is the first uh rap song i ever
learned all the lyrics to way back in
the day when i was a small child
it's off the king of rock record
by the kings run dmc
the song is you talk too much and it
goes like this
you talk too much
they say that a bunch then he goes hey
you over there i know about your kind
you're like the independent network news
on channel nine everywhere that you go
no matter where you at i said you talk
about this and you talk about that
when the cat took your tongue i said you
took it right back your mouth is so big
one bite would kill a big mac
you talk about people you don't even
know when you talk about places you
never go you talk about your girl from
head to toe i said your mouth's moving
fast and your brain's moving slow you
talk too much and you never shut up
i said you talk too much humble you
never shut
up i love run dmc
and i love you all good folks
see you soon on the dr john de luna show